complaint for GR sexual imposition B at
third degree case number 2023 C
03777 okay warn on a complaint take you
down to jail an Ohio man now faces
nearly 50 sexual assault allegations
after operating a socalled party house
inviting children over to swim and
keeping hidden cameras throughout his
home the entire arrest caught on body
camera video you just walking for
everything out yeah I get you back
it happened on November 18th in Union
Township Ohio about 30 minutes outside
of Cincinnati that's when 60-year-old
Monty Cecil was arrested on charges of
rape gross sexual imposition illegal use
of a minor in nudity oriented material
and voyerism body came camera video
shows police arrive at Cecil's job and C
him off in handcuffs I'm walking
over walking out you all right are you
guys hanging in
there I just do a real quick P down
anything all right we far right Cruiser
okay yep
thanks just walking for I empty
everything out yeah I get you
back
you want anything on your Stu
right P here some keys and threee pocket
just
in up
there and keys in that one and inside
bottom one too and there's a little
metal cap in there too I do believe
there's a midle metal cap in
the should be it
I I
the
as seen on the video Cecil is compliant
when it comes to his arrest even when
authorities mention the serious nature
of the crime just confirming uh Monte L
SE y 11 13 of 63 yep all right here's
this complaint for G sexual imposition B
of third degree case number 2023 CRA
03777 okay warn on a complaint take you
down to jail leading up to his arrest
prosecutors alleged Cecil hosted a party
house where he would invite nine and
10-year-old kids over to swim officials
say that when the children were sleeping
Cecil would sexually assault them all of
this came to light on November 17th when
a 10-year-old girl found a a picture of
herself on Cecil's phone in the pic she
was asleep and naked right away the girl
told her parents when searching his
phone investigators found that picture
they say it had been taken two weeks
prior as body camera video shows Cecil
maintains composure while being
transported to jail even discussing
country music with the responding
officer you can put me
on stand
by Joe you got any hand s
yeah nice
Bud 35 it's in reference that 23 180 13
18013 it's going to be that
[Music]
male
boy huh
yeah alltime country music wh and
Jenny's well Jenny's my all time
favorite I like George Jen I like George
I like
Merl I like all those guys Johnny Cash
well I always kind of
kind of lean towards whing I just liked
his brandom music and style it wasn't it
wasn't a cliche type was kind of hey I
experienced it I'm sing about it
so yeah they did they did they did they
did experience it Ain no doubt about it
yeah I mean no Johnny Cash George
Jones you know they didn't live a dull
life I can tell yeah whether it was a
good life it was definitely wasn't it
wasn't dll for him Cecil only complains
once when he mentions that the handcuffs
are restrictive what is it they really
put
like oh
yeah yeah they're not they're not
comfortable at all we should be here in
a little bit should
be how long you work down there
[Music]
but for most of the ride Cecil remains
silent in the back
seat
copy
39 39 cic
complement at 4648 4648 as in Road at J
P reference damage
to
11 12 39 your pleasure I
can
[Music]
I believe that's going to be the 39 of
that signal 70
subject we
looking
get
here cport
[Music]
now
video shows the next moments when Cecil
arrives at the
[Music]
jail
there we
go yeah kind of got there you go got it
got got it try to get my other foot out
there you
go walk right right
there oh sorry actually I got come over
here for a
second come over here for a second I GRS
up real
fast all
go around that
car I'll cut you off right
here s to the right
Y come
in investigators say there are multiple
victims in Cecil's case but have not yet
released the specifics right now he's
being held on $1 million Bond reporting
for long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie